[Music]
Nike is a huge company in their decision
to make colin kaepernick the star of
their ad campaign wasn't simply a
political statement it was a business
decision is it paying off well sales
surged in the days immediately after the
announcement of the campaign but Nike
stock is still down from from where it
was at the beginning of the week Jesse
Kelly is a Marine Corps combat veteran
he also hosted Jesse Kelly show on KPRC
950 in Houston
he's a former congressional candidate
and he joins us tonight so Jesse do you
think this was a leaving aside your
personal views on this do you think was
a wise decision for Nike to do this no
it was idiotic and I understand they're
putting out these statements down now
that how they're focusing on the urban
environment on how they're focusing on
younger people but what sense does it
make to focus on left-wing social
justice warrior younger people those are
poor people you need to focus on the
entire country Nike was built on the
back of Michael Jordan who said
Republicans buy shoes too that makes no
sense to alienate anybody they could
have chose anybody for this thirtieth
anniversary of the just do it campaign
and they chose Colin Kaepernick and that
doesn't make them they act like that
means they're changing the world just
because you write a jackass doesn't mean
you're Jesus Christ I'm so struck by the
term social justice warrior I mean I
really believe in social justice really
strongly but I don't hate America these
people hate America I mean the whole
point of this is you're kneeling during
our national anthem a bit you know the
basic symbol of our country is an attack
on the United States why do people who
say they identify with social justice
have to hate the country that's provided
more social justice in any country in
history
well it's no different than the people
who love abortion that call it women's
reproductive rights Tucker the left leg
survives based on changing language
they've master language and they try to
shame other people when they try to
speak the truth and you're right Colin
Kapernick he's just the guys he's an
employee who violated the one rule of
every employee in the country and that's
make sure your talent outweighs your
baggage and he didn't he declared
America to be racist when you add in the
he reads defenses like Helen Keller he's
out of the NFL that's pretty funny but
wait I don't think you're giving him his
due I mean Nike told us that he is the
bravest person in human history
certainly American history I mean you
served the United States Marine Corps in
combat did you ever meet anyone as brave
as Colin Kaepernick I'll tell you all
the brothers in arms that I served with
none of them had the bravery to make 39
million dollars in the NFL and then move
on to get paid by one of the biggest
shoe brands in the world I have to tell
you I think you should get some sort of
medal of honor whatever civilians can
make Jesse thank you for coming on
tonight was great to see you